I think basically optic tamla it says
that the glue that holds local
government together proper procedures
accountability the difference between
officers and members or got blood
norfolk's we put in some commissioners
who start the process of retraining the
staff putting in proper procedures and
I'm very confident that when we come out
of the other side that will have a
council that everybody can be proud of I
think there are some people who thought
to community cohesion was more important
than ensuring that things were run
straight forward and honestly and I
think that what happened in Tower
Hamlets were happened in rather and what
happened elsewhere demonstrates that
he's massively important that you put
people first met please so caring for a
lot of stick by the judge that were
described as the three wise monkeys I
think we're looking from the police is a
court of action some recommendations to
ensure that the kind of things that we
saw in Tower Hamlets and elsewhere will
never be seen again in the UK
I think we need to look very carefully
about the Electoral Commission they
haven't been particularly helpful or
useful in tackling corruption in local
government indeed gave tower hamlets I
think a gold star rating for there for
that performance I think that is
completely unacceptable and it would
look two ways in which we might be able
to improve the function I'm very worried
i think tower hamlets is an important
sign post in the road and that what
happened there could happen elsewhere
and i think that the procedures the way
in which county councils are run that
their elections have become a little
slack and will look to improve them well
that we is up to the politicians it's up
to the officials to ensure the bridge
people always have faith in the
electoral system I think they've we've
seen a number of abuses in recent years
but used to say that ours were the
fairest and most incorruptible system
that proved not to be the case and is up
to those authority to do something about
it
you